[Music]
you are looking at a recent test flight
by a star hopper rocket at SpaceX is
launch site in Texas the hook the
Hubbard test was the latest move by
SpaceX founder that's Elon Musk to
eventually take humans to Mars the
launch site is next to a tiny
neighborhood east of Brownsville it's
called no kidding Boca Chica Boca Chica
where the rocket company is transform
life mark Strassmann visited the
community to learn how neighbors are
reacting to all of this so mark what are
the what are they saying in the
neighborhood well let's put it this way
sometimes there's that new neighbor that
everyone can't stop talking about for
better or for worse and that's what's
happening now in Boca Chica which
thought of itself as an itty bitty beach
in fishing village barely on the map and
then the future of space moved in you
move to a place like Boca Chica to get
away from it all there is a beach one
main street and only a couple of dozen
residents tops perfect for retirement
maria porter thought until the rocket
company moved in next door how often do
you glance next door just to see what's
going on her neighbor is SpaceX Elon
Musk's company picked this spot to
develop tests and maybe someday launch
its new spaceship called starship it's
designed to flight cargo and crew to the
moon and even Mars they could be
building a spaceship to take people to
Mars right next door to you and that's
exciting
oh gosh yes yeah you when you're juicing
your oranges and you're looking at a
spaceship I would be talking to my mom
going can you believe this after all
where else can you see this a starship
prototype called Starhawk it navigated
around the plants in Maria's front yard
the launch pad is about a mile and a
half down the road but test days are the
real game-changer here beaches close the
town's main access road closes and
deputies hand out warnings to residents
there is a risk that a malfunction will
a overpressure event that can break
windows pointer boarded up her house
love-hate relationship oh yeah
flip the coin you get heads is yay
Rajesh can bow look what we've got
coming for the future and then on the
backside it's like where the hell do I
go now
I mean I can't stay here forever no
question the neighborhood has changed
it's just a feeling of encroachment ask
homeowners Cheryl Stevens about it and
she launches there behaving as if this
is Cape Canaveral and it's not it's not
a military base it's just a regular
neighborhood and a public beach and the
state highway and suddenly because
they're here stop the presses everything
has to change for SpaceX do you
understand their frustrations I can
certainly appreciate their frustrations
but I got a look at the big picture
judge Eddie Trevino jr. is the top
elected official in Cameron County it's
one of the poorest in Texas SpaceX could
bring in hundreds of new jobs and tens
of millions of dollars I think that's
that's a big big win potential win for
us I feel bad for those people but
hopefully they'll understand and
appreciate it at the end of the day this
was beneficial for the entire area which
brings us back to Maria pointer on
launch day she had a front-row seat
she watched this test launch it sensed
our hopper about 500 feet in the air
and landed a minute later she was
thrilled but when she thinks about the
future of space here she worries about
her own it's bittersweet this was
supposed to be the forever house and now
it's not now it's not what would you say
to Elon Musk as your neighbor when do I
have to move that's what I would ask him
when do I have to move so I get this in
the last few days Maria pointer and
several other homeowners have received
letters from SpaceX like this one
offering to buy their homes at three
times a fair market value
SpaceX says the offer is non-negotiable
and expires in two weeks sellers would
get to come back for VIP launch viewings
and Elon Musk says he'll visit Boca
Chica next weekend to outline his
company's future there this is a crazy
part of the world these days yeah that's
quite an offer I'd negotiate go ahead he
says not negotiable I think he might be
able to go to four times what a great
story all the whole in it just what they
get to see I hope they're saying well
you know I feel sorry for them but I
love that image of the rocket ship
rounding the corner in front of her what
do you say our rocket ship runs over
your flower but what about the
retirement we bargained for yeah that's
better watch out for an overpressure
event it could break your window thank
you very much